[MUSIC PLAYING]
RODNEY PRIESTLEY:
Research is exciting
because it's cutting edge.
And this is the
type of excitement
that we're trying to share
with the REU students
when they come in to
campus, is that, hey, look,
you're not just doing research,
you're actually doing something
that no one's ever done before.
CRAIG ARNOLD: But they all
get this unique Princeton
experience.
We have resources that rival
any resources anywhere.
And to be able to share
with those kinds of students
what I'm able to do today
is very meaningful for me.
RODNEY PRIESTLEY: REU itself
stands for Research Experience
for Undergraduates.
It's an NSF-supported
program that
allows us to bring upwards to
10 to 20 students to campus
during the summertime to
undertake research along
with a faculty adviser.
We very often recruit
students from institutions
that are not Ph.D.
research institutions
and so students may not
have the opportunity
to do research at the level
that we're offering them
through the Princeton
REU program.
And so it gives
them the opportunity
to actually decide and
to learn whether or not
academic research is
actually right for them.
ILANA KRAUSE: Currently,
I attend the University
of Florida and I'm majoring
in materials science
and engineering.
So here at Princeton,
I'm working
with Dr. Richard
Register on a project
about catalytic hydrogenation.
Catalytic hydrogenation
ends up altering
the thermal properties.
And so you can see
it being applied
to the pharmaceutical industry,
the food industry, in oil,
and it really has a potential
to impact people's lives
on a day-to-day basis.
JON WILSON: My main
interest in research
is developing technologies
for renewable energy
like solar cells and
new battery chemistries
to store that energy.
So I'm working on researching
lithium ion batteries here
with Dr. Arnold.
At Princeton there's a lot
more equipment available to me
and also the ratio of
professors to students
seems to be quite a bit higher.
And so you get more availability
for one-on-one interaction
here.
LEE HAMPTON: I'm working
with a polymer that
is actually very prevalent
in a lot of household items.
And what I'm doing is
I'm trying to alter
physical properties without
chemically degrading it.
You can't say you're an
expert or you know that much.
It's just the opportunity
to be in the environment
and be in the atmosphere with
all these other guys who've
been working on this like
three, four, five years
and see how far they've
come in their research.
And knowing that
some of their work
could very well be published.
And talking with
professors who actually
have published research and
stuff like that -- it's special.
CRAIG ARNOLD: You
know, for me when
I went to graduate school
coming out of a small school,
having a little bit of research
experience under my belt
really gave me a lot of
confidence, a lot of ability,
to step right in and
be able to, in a sense,
compete with
everyone else, to be
at the same level
as everyone else.
And so these little
experiences like that, I think,
can be very valuable.
And I really appreciate
to be in a position
where I can share
that with others.
ILANA KRAUSE: The
experience that I've
had so far at Princeton has
blown my expectations away.
Being on the brink of
discovery and being
able to really
just try new things
and do really
interesting experiments.
LEE HAMPTON: The more
you talk to people
and the more you get
around, the more you
understand that everything
is kind of interconnected.
And even though someone
else is focusing
on something completely
different, nine times out of 10
they're doing something,
there's a certain aspect
in their research that could
very well pertain to yours.
ILANA KRAUSE: You're
able to engage
with other students
in the REU program
in an intellectual
environment and I
think that's a really,
really rewarding thing
that not all REU programs have.
RODNEY PRIESTLEY:
And so we're hoping
that they enjoy the program,
they meet new friends,
they do interesting and
exciting new science,
they learn a lot about their
research in their new areas,
and they not only get excited
about the science, but also the
in the University and
the possibility of coming
back here in a few years
as graduate students.
CRAIG ARNOLD: I'm really looking
for them to come out of it
and say, 'Wow, I loved this!
I want to do more of this.’
And I want them to think
that, 'Hey, wait a minute,
you know, I could do this.
I could see myself
doing research.
I could see myself being
involved in science.’
And for some of these
students, they never
thought of that before.
[MUSIC PLAYING]